herzlich willkommen zu zdf heute live es
sind schockierende bilder die uns aus
dem westen kanadas und aus dem
nordwesten der usa erreichen dort tobt
eine derzeit eine extreme hitzewelle mit
historischem ausmaß fast 50 grad dort wo
es normalerweise angenehme temperaturen
zu dieser jahreszeit von 22 grad gibt
das hat man dort noch nicht erlebt und
mehrere hundert menschen sollen bereits
opfer dieser extremen temperaturen
geworden sein
es ist wie in einem ofen sagen manche
menschen andere sagen es ist wie im
death valley in der wüste im tal des
todes die wissenschaftler sagen dass der
klimawandel die trockenheit und die
hitze halt noch extrem verstärkt und der
gouverneur von kalifornien der norden
kaliforniens ist eben auch stark
betroffen schreibt auf twitter
der klimawandel ist hier extremes wetter
klimawandel wir warten auf ihre fragen
beteiligen sie sich stellen sie fragen
kommentieren sie teilen sie ihre
erfahrungen mit uns denn wir wollen
zusammen die zusammenhänge erklären
und da wollen wir sprechen mit dem
wissenschaftsjournalisten dirk steffens
und zum anderen können wir sprechen mit
der direktorin des
alfred-wegener-instituts in bremerhaven
frau professor antje boetius über die
neuesten erkenntnisse der polarstern
expedition und die neuesten aktuellen
modelle zum klimawandel
zunächst aber einen überblick über das
extreme wetter die hitzewelle die feuer
die katastrophalen zustände im
kanadischen british columbia
viel zeit bleibt den einwohnern von
litten nicht das wichtigste
zusammenpacken und dann nichts wie weg
wenig später war die feuerwalze da und
von litten nicht mehr viel übrig ob es
alle rechtzeitig raus geschafft haben
ist unklar
einheimische medien berichten von
mehreren vermissten
auch aus anderen teilen der provinz
british columbia werden dutzende
waldbrände gemeldet mehr als 60 in 24
stunden einfach zu viele um dagegen
anzukommen
oft können die feuerwehrleute nur
zusehen wie sie die flammen richtung
häuser fressen
hey leute sieht so aus als müssten wir
jetzt dringend abbauen
das feuer breitete sich weiter aus und
kommt jetzt in unsere richtung dürre und
hitze machen es dem feuer leicht sich
rasch auszubreiten
fast 50 grad im schatten wurden gemessen
so viel wie noch nie in kanada für viele
viel zu heiß mehr als 100 menschen sind
an der hitze schon gestorben die
behörden haben extra so genannte kühles
center eingerichtet in tiefgaragen unter
der erde ist die hitze etwas
erträglicher
wir setzen verschiedene maßnahmen um um
die menschen zu schützen und fordern sie
auf in eigens eingerichtete callcenter
zu kommen
ich denke in den letzten tagen ist uns
eine große lektion erteilt worden die
klimakrise ist keine erfindung sie ist
absolut real und so glauben auch viele
experten dass diese hitzewelle nicht die
letzte sein wird
hier kommt es zu einem solchen
extremwetter zu einer solch extremen
hitze da wo es so was noch nie gegeben
hat einer der die dinge sehr gute
erklären kann es unser terra ex-mann und
wirtschaftswissenschaft journalist dirk
steffens hallo dirk schön dass du zeit
hast hast du das ist die erste
natürliche frage was da gerade im westen
kanadas passiert wie ist das ganze zu
erklären das ist ja wirklich nicht
normal würden die menschen sagen ja
nicht normal ist hier noch eine große
untertreibung man muss sagen
statistisch betrachtet gibt es so eine
wetterlage nur etwa alle tausend jahre
das ist also ein sehr sehr seltenes
phänomen aber erstmal ein natürliches
phänomen die meteorologen sprechen dann
von einer sogenannten omega wetterlage
das kann man sich vorstellen wie so ein
bisschen ballon der nach oben immer
breiter wird und so eine kuppel hat das
ist ein hochdruckgebiet und ein
hochdruckgebiet bringt trockenheit und
wärme mit sich und das verharren sie ja
schon ungewöhnlich lange an einer stelle
und deshalb können die wälder und die
böden austrocknen links und rechts von
diesem hochdruckgebiet sitzen
tiefdruckgebiete und halten das fest das
ist also die lokale wetterlage und ein
selten
aber erstmal natürliches phänomen dass
zu diesen ungewöhnlichen hitzewelle
führen kann
also ihr habt wird das ganze aber dann
durch den klimawandel also du würdest
sagen diese diese omega form dieser
omega konstellation das ist ein
wetterphänomen und das ist jetzt
sozusagen natürlich die brennende frage
was was ist wetter und wie kommt jetzt
der klimawandel ins spiel
ja das ist natürlich immer die frage der
fragen dabei einzelne wetterphänomene
sind kein klima das muss man sich mal
wieder klar machen klima ist das wetter
im durchschnitt von 30 jahren also diese
hitze kuppeln diese omega wertanlagen
die sind erstmal natürlich die gibt es
auch fast überall auf der welt auch in
deutschland kann sowas in seltenen
fällen mal vorkommen aber jetzt haben
wir gegen die besondere lage das auf
dieses natürliche phänomen noch die
menschen gemacht der erwärmung drauf
kommt das ändert sich also kurz gesagt
der menschengemachte klimawandel macht
extreme noch extremer und dass diese
wetterlage so lange an einem ort
verharrt das hängt mit den jetstreams
zusammen mit dem verlauf der großen
luftströme auch in hoher höhe und da
kann man schon seit vielen jahren
beobachten dass durch den menschen
gemachte klimawandel sich vieles
verändert also man muss sich vorstellen
die warme luft steigt nach oben in die
äquatorregion sonst in richtung polen wo
sie kühler wird wieder absinken der
jetstream der hat so ein bisschen hin
und her auf diesem weg aber er hat
normalerweise wie so eine schlange also
verändert sich und schiebt durch diese
bewegung dann tief und hochdruckgebiete
durcheinander und deshalb bleibt eine
wetterlage normalerweise nicht so lange
besteht aber jetzt seit jahren
beobachtet die wissenschaft schon dass
der jetstream in seinem bett bleibt also
der bleibt immer in dieser einfordert
das heißt wenn in dieser ausspruch dass
gerade so ein hochdruckgebiet sitzt kann
jetzt nicht mehr weg geschoben
man kann sehr lange auf einer stelle
sitzen und genau das passiert gerade in
kanada
also das heißt wenn manche sagen naja
man muss ja unterscheiden das ist wetter
und das ist der klimawandel
und wenn manch einer sagt das eine hat
mit dem anderen nichts zu tun dann
würdest du sagen richtig es sind zwei
verschiedene sachen die aber nicht
getrennt zu sehen sind richtig genauso
das ist im grunde sowie einen tag in
deinem leben
der tag in deinem leben ist natürlich
nicht dein leben
aber daneben besteht halt aus einzel tag
und der einzelne tag darin diese lebens
kann ja auch dein ganzes leben
grundsätzlich verändern und so ähnlich
sind klima und wetter miteinander
verknüpft es sind verschiedene dinge die
aber untrennbar miteinander verbunden
sind
heißt das jetzt im grunde genommen dirk
dass man auch sagen muss wir sehen da im
fernen kanada sind dramatische bilder
aber wenn wir sie zu hause sehen können
wir natürlich sagen mensch das ist weit
weg aber das was da passiert und wenn du
sagst da ist eine omega
wetterkonstellation müssen wir uns dann
doch auch sehr gedanken machen wenn wir
diese bilder sehen und sagen da sind wir
nicht weit von weg sondern das hängt
auch mit wetterlagen bei uns zusammen
nicht mit wetterlagen beliebt bei uns
aber wir müssen uns genau die gleichen
gedanken machen solche hitze kuppeln
entstehen auch in deutschland und auch
ich erinnere an die super sommer ich
glaube es war 2018 mit hitzerekorden
auch hier bei uns in deutschland dann im
jahr davor der extrem verregnete sommer
oder noch vor zwei drei tagen hatten wir
in bayern hatten wir so extreme
hagelschauern hier mitten im sommer
wetter extreme werden durch den
klimawandel extremer und das hat
natürlich gravierende folgen für alle
bereiche des lebens für den verkehr für
den bahnverkehr für die landwirtschaft
für uns alle
und da sieht man eben dass der
klimawandel für uns alle dramatischen
folgen hat und im grunde muss man den
rüstet aufschreien wenn man die bei euch
im filmbeitrag gerade sieht der
kanadische politiker noch im sommer 2021
glaubt sagen zu müssen
der klimawandel ist keine erfindung also
wer so was meint in diesem jahr noch
sagen zu müssen
wir hatten wirklich den schuss nicht
gehört ja weil es mag ja durchaus sein
dass manch einer sagt naja guck mal
letztes jahr vorletztes jahr oder oder
2009 10 18 hast du gesagt er hat mir ja
extreme hitze hier an guck mal
jetzt regnet es doch bei uns ach was
heißt es denn klimawandel erderwärmung
etc aber du wirst ja unterstützt genau
das was so erklärt dass der leiter des
deutschen wetterdienstes hat jetzt
gesagt und schickedanz dass diese
unwetter die wir jetzt haben also nicht
die extreme hitze bei uns sondern eben
die unwetter du sagst es nicht landshut
steht unter wasser bayern läuft ab etc
dass das genau in diesem kontext steht
der sagte nämlich auch dass diese
sommerliche abwechslung von dürre und
starkregen bei uns genau dieses phänomen
ist dass es eben immer mehr zu diesen ex
rehm wetterlagen kommt jetzt haben wir
konkrete fragen an dich
dirk welchen einfluss du kannst es
vielleicht nochmal erklären fragt jens
meyer über youtube welchen einfluss hat
der jetstream beim menschen gemachten
klimawandel erklärt dass mal was
verursacht der mensch wenn wir sagen das
trägt zum klimawandel bei und wie hat
das die auswirkung auf den jetstream
denn du hast ja gesagt da hat sich was
beim jet stream verändert ja man muss
sich vielleicht als erstes mal ganz kurz
klarmachen warum gibt es überhaupt wind
und winter sind ja auch beim feuer in
kanada jetzt ein entscheidender faktor
warum gibt es überhaupt will
weil die atmosphäre versucht
temperaturunterschiede auf der erde
auszugleichen also darum es besonders
warm ist in den äquator region
da steigt die luft nach oben in der
atmosphäre und dann fließt die richtung
pole
dort ist es kälter das heißt die luft
sinkt langsam wieder ab und strömt dann
oberflächennah das sind die sogenannten
passatwinde zurück wenn die
äquatorregion das ist die grundlast
bewegung also wenn der gibt es um
temperaturunterschiede auszugleichen
wenn sich jetzt aber die temperatur auf
der erde verändert dann verändert sich
damit natürlich auch das luftströmung
gefüge also wenn zum beispiel der
unterschied zwischen der äquatorregion
und dem nordpol geringer wird und das
ist gerade der fall weil die klima bei
der klima anstieg am nordpol sie viel
schneller geht ungefähr doppelt so
schnell wie im rest der welt dann
verändern sich die
temperaturunterschiede und deshalb
verändert sich auch diese gesamte
luftströme und die triggert halt den
jetstream und der wiederum ist einer der
hauptverantwortlichen für unser wetter
wenn sich dadurch sozusagen das gefüge
verändert so verstehe ich dich jetzt mal
ganz einfach dann hat das eben sagst du
konsequenzen und eben nicht nur für
kanada sondern eben für jede region auf
dem globus und insofern kommen und
insofern ist es auch insofern
nachvollziehbar dass jetzt hier besorgte
fragen kommen die fangen mal einmal an
fernando schreibt über youtube wird denn
der äquator dann irgendwann zur
todeszone gibt es einschätzungen zur
unbewohnbarkeit von regionen in
abhängigkeit dieser globalen
temperaturerhöhung ich würde jetzt mal
in klammern setzen dieser globalen
klimaveränderungen wie du gesagt hast ja
es gibt da sehr konkret
der abschätzung der weltklimarat hat
sich mit dieser frage auch schon
beschäftigt und ausgerechnet wie der
anteil der unbewohnbaren millionen auf
der edel zunimmt und das ist natürlich
dramatisch wollen wir ja dann region
verlieren in denen jetzt noch einen
gewissen grenzen ackerbau und viehzucht
betrieben werden kann die menschen leben
also es gibt halt eine gewisse
temperatur schwelle ab der wird auch
menschliches leben dauerhaft ganz
schwierig weil sich dann ein weiß ketten
zu ersetzen
also wir haben jetzt ja zum beispiel in
kanada das ist glaube ich die zahl die
aktuell gelesen habe man bereits knapp
500 sogenannte hitzetod und man muss
sich ja auch noch klar machen dass hitze
tote im totenschein sehr selten als tot
als grund für ihren tod hitze stehen
haben sondern es sind ja dann herz
kreislauf erkrankung oder andere volk
erkrankungen also so sieht man ja die
region die unbewohnbar werden
insbesondere rund um den äquator die
werden wachsen und das macht natürlich
auch den bevölkerungsdruck in den
anderen regierungen dann noch größer
also wenn man allein daran denkt das ist
ja nicht nur so dass wir wegen hitze tot
umfallen wenn ackerflächen nicht mehr
bebaubar sind hat das ja eben auch
dramatische folgen da ist es schon
erwähnt ismael 04 schreibt über youtube
nächste sozusagen besorgte frage drohen
uns denn in den nächsten 30 jahren auch
solche temperaturen in europa kann uns
ein solcher jetstream auch heimsuchen
schreibt er hat einen kann ein solcher
jetstream so eine veränderung beim jet
stream am ende auch diese folgen haben
dass wir am ende auch so einen glutofen
in europa haben naja man muss mal sehen
in kanada liegen diese temperaturen wir
haben jetzt fast 50 grad gehabt rund um
lücken die liegen ungefähr 18 grad über
dem langjährigen mittel also fast 20
grad über der durchschnittstemperatur
aber wenn wir bei legen 2018 hatten wir
ja auch in deutschland völlig neue
rekorde
also bei 40 grad sind wir hier ja auch
schon angekommen also ist die etwas
traurige antwort leider ja vielleicht
nicht so schnell in dem extrem ausmaß
aber wir müssen mit mehr wetterextremen
rechnen und man muss übrigens auch klar
machen die sache heißt ja auch
klimawandel und nicht immer nur
klimaerwärmung weil es erstmal heißt das
klima verändert sich es wird anders als
zuvor war nicht immer zwangsläufig
wärmer in jedem jahr in jeder sie es
jeder region aber das klima gefüge
insgesamt verändert sich und unsere
pflanzen und tiere unser ganzes
ökosystem auch hier in deutschland ist
eben auch dass eingerichtet hat sich auf
das eingestellt was in den letzten
tausend jahren hier üblich war
und wenn sich das verändert geraten hat
die gesamten biosysteme durcheinander
man sagt ja bei der tierwelt eben auch
das ökosystem ist gestört
hier ist es sozusagen das wetter als
system was verändert wird was gestört
wird und dann hat es eben folgen die wir
wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht abschätzen
können oder was würdest du sagen wir
menschen können da noch einfluss darauf
nehmen haben wir da noch eine chance an
dem rechen zu drehen also zurück zu
drehen oder wird zu sagen da ist was los
getriggert da ist eine spirale
wir können eigentlich nur zuschauen also
das ist keine option hier ist optimismus
wirklich pflicht denn es gibt ja keine
alternative es gibt keinen planeten b es
gibt kein anderes klima das heißt wir
menschen müssen dieses problem in den
griff kriegen wir müssen uns mit zwei
fragen gleichzeitig beschäftigen erster
wie können wir den weiteren
temperaturanstieg begrenzen
jetzt gab gerade eine neue studie von
klimaforschern denn die gesagt haben das
15 grad ziel ist noch möglich es ist
unwahrscheinlich schwierig ist zu
erreichen
die gesamte menschheit müsste
geschlossen handeln und wir wissen alle
aus erfahrung dass das nicht immer
klappt bei krone arzt ein bisschen
besser geklappt und das zweite ist wir
müssen auch darüber diskutieren wie wir
an einer wärmeren sich verändernden welt
leben also ich war neulich zum beispiel
auf einem kongress mit landwirten und
landwirte haben da wird schon ganz
natürlich darüber diskutiert welche
anderen pflanzen man jetzt auf deutschen
äckern angebaut weil die sorten und
arten mit dem man bisher gearbeitet hat
oft nicht mehr funktionieren durch den
klimawandel also wir müssen gleichzeitig
versuchen in weiteren anstieg der
temperaturen zu begrenzen aber den
anstieg nicht mehr verhindern können
darauf müssen wir uns einstellen mit
höherem gleichen an den deutschen küsten
mit anderen pflanzen auf den äckern und
vielleicht auch mit einer anderen
architektur den städten damit wir nicht
zu viel hitze tote zu beklagen haben
werden also insofern vielen vielen dank
sozusagen für deinen appell dass du
sagst wir müssen optimistisch sein aber
wir müssen dringend sozusagen die ärmel
hoch
apple nicht nur bei corona sondern vor
allen dingen auch was das klima angeht
und man kann noch einiges erreichen und
sich darauf einstellen den optimismus
den nehmen wir mit und danken ganz
herzlich für seine erklärung hören wir
gerne zu mascus und liebe grüße
wir wollen weiter reden einfach das
gespräch mit dirk steffens weiter führen
jetzt mit einer auch echten klimawandel
experte nämlich der direktorin des
deutschen alfred wegener instituts in
bremerhaven das alfred-wegener-institut
forscht ja vor allem zum klimawandel in
den polarregionen und zu den
auswirkungen auf unsere mittleren
breiten sozusagen und sie war schon
häufig auf expedition mit dabei auch in
der zentral antarktis v professor antje
boetius ich grüße sie ganz herzlich
grüßen bremerhaven
sie kennen den dirk steffens bestens und
insofern passt das auch dass man
anschließen kann
bürger deutlich gemacht dass feuer und
hitze in kanada etwas zu tun haben mit
dem gesamtgefüge klima auf unserem
planeten erde auf diesem globus und dass
man die dinge nicht getrennt sehen kann
ich habs gerade gesagt sie haben ja vor
allen dingen den fokus das augenmerk auf
die arktis wie können wir jetzt im
grunde um eine brücke herstellen und
sagen das was da im westen kanadas
passiert das hat auch was damit zu tun
nämlich brücke klimawandel mit dem was
wir vom alfred-wegener-institut auf
unseren expedition in die arktis
beobachten berg hat es ja schon prima
erklärt was der zusammenhang ist mit dem
jetstream und wir haben bei uns im
forschungsprogramm den ansatz zu
überlegen was macht jetzt eigentlich das
ist die rolle des meereises was ist die
rolle der kalte polarluft die hat der
hat ja auch eben erwähnt und wie ist das
was wir das beobachten nämlich ein
stetiger rückgang des meereises von
mittlerweile schon 13 prozent pro zehn
jahre
was für eine rolle spielt das eigentlich
und dazu haben wir verschiedene
untersuchungsmöglichkeiten natürlich
sind wir mit dem eisbrecher polarstern
vor ort und
zweitens haben wir fernab methoden
arbeiten wir mit der deutschen raumfahrt
aber auch internationalen beobachtern
zusammen wir vergessen das meereis und
drittens ist ganz wichtig wir nutzen
simulation wir benutzen erdsystem und
klimamodelle können sozusagen in die
vergangenheit reisen bevor der mensch
co2 in die luft gepustet hat und können
uns die option und unsere pfade auch vor
neben sagen wenn wir so weitermachen wie
bisher was kommt daraus nämlich
wahrscheinlich schon 2030 mehr als mehr
im sommer oder wenn wir es schaffen in
green deal und alle versprechungen
zusammen umzusetzen wenn wir also
deutlich unter zwei grad bleiben was
kommt dann raus und diese optionen
können wir simulieren und was jetzt eben
tatsächlich so wichtig ist für alle zu
verstehen ein ganz großer anteil dieser
hitze phänomene ist einfach die menge an
co2 in der atmosphäre
denn das 4 2 ist ein treibhausgas und
wir können so ganz genau untersuchen
das macht bei uns die klima modellierung
und ovation herum
man kann es genau seine simulation
machen mit dem co2 vor der
industrialisierung heute und in der
zukunft und das sind richtig ein paar
gerade oben braucht jetzt einfach das
mehr an co2 in der atmosphäre in so
einer extremen wettersituation zu
verantworten hat also da machen sie
deutlich dass der blick von ihnen zurück
in der forschung ganz entscheidend ist
für den blick nach vorne und was wir
jetzt tun müssen wir haben ganz viele
fragen die daran anschließen kommen wir
sofort zu aber wir wollen mal schauen
nur ein paar tage zurück schauen denn da
hat es die nächste expedition die
aktuellste expedition der polarstern
gegeben die war wieder unterwegs so ist
noch gar nicht so lange her dass eben
sie ihr institut die ergebnisse dieser
expedition mosaik bekannt gegeben haben
das müssen wir uns mal ganz kurz
anschauen und dann kommen wir zu den
fragen und antworten
bei minus 40 grad winterstürmen und den
teils wochenlanger dunkelheit bohrten
forscher aus 20 nationen tief ins eis
kerne zu entnehmen
tauchten sondern ins meer und ließen
wetterballons aufsteigen eine erkenntnis
der spektakulären expedition das eis der
arktis hat sich schneller zurückgezogen
als jemals zuvor
wir haben dabei mit unseren eigenen
augen gesehen dieses steht
es ist ein schwieriger heißt der hat das
überhaupt nichts zu retten
wenn man das marode und nicht schafft
müssen heiß am nordpol im sommer 2020
gesehen haben miteinander tatsächlich
manchmal zweifel über kommen einen grund
für den beschleunigten eisverlust sehen
die forscher im zufluss von wärmeren
wassermassen aus dem atlantik das zeigen
aktuelle studien die wir aus der mosel
expeditionen gewinnen konnten dass wir
eine zunehmende attraktivität der
praktischen wassermassen beobachten
strich dass wir einen einfluss von
warmwasser haben und damit dass mehr als
schmilzt sowohl im sommer als auch im
winter auf 60 eisbären trafen die
forscher während ihrer reise der
lebensraum der großen raubtiere wird
kleiner
einige wissenschaftler sagen voraus dass
die arktis bereits im sommer 2035 und
nicht erst mitte des jahrhunderts
eisfrei sein könnte
jetzt haben wir diese spektakulären
bilder gesehen und haben auch diese töne
gehört die ja eben doch erschreckend
sind diese erkenntnisse
ich reiche einfach mal so zu sagen die
bitte von kairo jockey über youtube
weiter kann sie es ist die frau wo ist
sie also könnten sie bitte noch mal
erklären was die polarstern im bezug auf
die atmosphäre herausgefunden hat das
die abnimmt oder so fragt er vielleicht
könnten sie noch mal das erklären ok ja
es war eine ganze reihe von
spektakulären erkenntnissen während des
einen jahres in der arktis mit dem
eisbrecher polarstern er entlang dieser
eisscholle immer weiter sortiert ist der
expeditionsleiter markus fix ist
atmosphärenphysiker und er hat unter
anderem auch ist teil der globalen
zeitreihen wie sich ozon verändert und
der klimawandel hat die auch die
atmosphäre die ist ja riesig die gitter
kilometer über die oberfläche der erde
und dort hat der klimawandel auf die
temperatur verschiedene effekte und dort
wo es besonders kalt ist ganz hoch oben
schwimmen lässt das ozon
so gab es ein gigantisches ozonloch was
die forscher beobachtet haben
was ganz wichtig zu verstehen ist auch
in der zukunft noch weiter auswirkungen
auf uns haben kann die fckw nutzung ist
verboten weltweit und wird
zurückgefahren
aber dennoch haben wir wechselwirkungen
einfach auch durch den klimawandel die
wir mit in die modelle einbauen müssen
was man auch gesehen hat ist die rolle
des meereises es ist unser weißes
schutzschild der erde
das weiß strahlt wärme zurück schreibt
sonnenlicht zurück dort wo das weiß auch
nicht kommt der dunkle ozean zum
vorschein und der nimmt seit eben unsere
forscherin stephanie angesagt der nimmt
ja wenn er dunkel ist wenn es ein
ziemlich schützt die sonnenlicht auf und
wird immer wärmer und wärmer und dann
kommt noch der atlantik dazu der schon
viel zu warm geworden ist und so
beschleunigt sich immer weiter die
schmelze des meeres mit von oben und von
unten und jetzt noch mal zurück zu den
wetterphänomenen die wir gerade gesehen
haben die hypothese ist und das müssen
wir eben noch erforschen dass der jet
schrieben der ins schleudern gekommen
ist und diese omega form bilden kann
der kriegt auch noch eine art von von
stabilisierung durch den polaren vortex
also um den nordpol herum dass starkem
wind und wenn das meer
verschwinden wird immer schwächer wir
können also wirklich vor einer
erheblichen verstärkung stehen und die
haben wir derzeit noch nicht in die
extreme mit einberechnet und das ist
einfach das was wir immer wieder sagen
müssen wir können als
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
natürlich immer raus waren neue
erkenntnisse mitbringen aber wir sind
nicht diejenigen die jetzt den schalter
umlegen
wir können nur waren so kann es nicht
weitergehen ist muss unbedingt sofort
ein ausstieg aus den fossilen energien
organisiert werden
trans unbedingt weil die konsequenzen
für alle menschen und alles leben auf
der erde ist hat auch dirk eben noch mal
gesagt es geht ja noch nicht mal nur
genussmenschen es geht um alles leben um
die pflanzen um die tiere um den meere
um die korallenriffe die wie das meereis
am stärksten auf die co2 emissionen
reagieren um all das geht es und wir
können würde wenn man die natur die wir
brauchen schützen
also sie haben ja wirklich mit
flammenden worten sehr deutlich gemacht
und vor augen geführt dass das ja so
eine spirale ist wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe dass das der ganze prozess der
klimawandel sozusagen immer schneller
wird weil ja sozusagen die veränderungen
also wenn warmes meerwasser dazu führt
das eis schmilzt dadurch sozusagen die
meere noch schneller noch mehr
temperatur gewinnen und damit das eis
noch standard also diese ganze spirale
und so weiter dass das schon dramatisch
ist ich will jetzt mal eine frage hier
aufgreifen von left to sea über youtube
wie sehr ärgert sich ärgern sie sich
über die taubheit der politik weltweit
was mir ja durch den kopf geht wenn sie
sagen dass schmilzt und es hat
dramatische folgen ist ja dass wir in
der letzten zeit konferenzen gehabt
haben von anrainerstaaten also arktis
anrainerstaaten russland usa norwegen
etc und da diskutiert man darüber wie
man denn die neuen passagen das alles
ist weg schiffe können fahren wie man
das regelt und wie man die bodenschätze
nutzen kann etc
da kann ich vielleicht verstehen oder
das meint vielleicht lässt sie wie sehr
ärgern sie sich darüber dass das
diskutiert wird aber nicht die folgen
sozusagen also erstmal muss ich da sagen
dass politiker das einzige ist was für
männer
haben um eine globale zukunft zu
organisieren was soll es denn sonst
seien es ist ja nicht der ein jeder von
uns kann etwas beitragen wir alle können
das tun aber lösen können wir das
globale problem wirklich nur mit der
besten international ausgerichteten
politik der die zukunft unserer kinder
wichtig ist und wie kommen wir da hin
was sind bei unsere schritte es gibt ja
schon hoffnung weil es jetzt über europa
ein großes paket geben wird was darauf 1
hat dass wir überhaupt einen
rahmenbedingungen haben als menschen
klimaneutraler arbeiten und leben zu
können
aber da drinnen stecken noch viele
baustellen und wir haben gewarnt da wird
es entscheidend sein wer bietet was an
wer bittet uns menschen an wie wir noch
besser energie sparen können wie der
regenerative energien nutzen können wie
unsere industrie wie unsere wirtschaft
an regenerativer energie kommt alle
diese fragen sind politisch zu lösen die
sonst jetzt machen sich unsere userinnen
und user gedanken philadelphia schreibt
über youtube beeindruckt oder wohl
nachdenklich geworden durch die letzten
bilder in dem vertrag werden die
eisbären aussterben wenn die polkappen
schmelzen oder können sie sich anpassen
die eisbären werden sicherlich nicht
mehr die eisbären sein die wir kennen
weil deren deren sind unheimlich
anpassungsfähigen lebewesen sie können
auch in interaktion mit städten treten
das ist sehr unangenehm werden können
sich von müll ernähren aber wir wollen
dass alle richter eisplatz sieht ja
schon in teilen an land und vermischt
sich mit braunbären also die arzt wird
einfach nicht die sein die wir kennen
sie wird nichts diese art von könig der
der weißen eiswüsten sein und das
schreckliche ist eben dass noch viel
mehr von den großen polaren sein wird
sind weil auf dem leben ja auch
obendrauf die waage was hat zb
untendrunter wale die die ice brauchen
auch es ist wirklich so wie auch bei den
koran ich versuche es immer als biologin
zu sagen wir müssen uns das leben als
ein netzwerk vorstellen es ist nicht die
einzige art schwindet sondern mit ihr
viele viele andere das ist so ein
dominospiel wallenstein umschmeißen land
fällt alles wenn wir die core eingriff
wer wie das mehr als verlieren werden
wenn wir nicht sofort anders handeln
dann verlieren wir damit ja auch eine
riesige menge an meereslebewesen die
dort leben die davon fressen die dort
ihren nachwuchs aufziehen und so müssen
wir uns das mehr als auch vorstellen
dass es unser weiße schutzschild was die
erde kühl und angenehm für uns menschen
temperiert aber es ist auch lebensraum
für so unglaublich viele arten sie keine
anderen rückzugsgebiete haben wir haben
deutlich gemacht es reicht dann auch
nicht nur einen domino stein wieder
aufzurichten wenn erst mal die ganze
kette darniederliegt israel 04 schreibt
über youtube modelle sagen bis 2030
könnte polareis komplett weg sein wie
wahrscheinlich ist dass und kurz vorher
als wir damit dass telefoniert da haben
sie gesagt ich checke noch mal mit
meinen kollegen wie die aktuellsten
modelle aussehen dann aussehen dann sind
sie also genau die richtige die ist man
jetzt die frage beantworten kann
ja das ist eine ganz wichtige frage auf
die zeit zuschauer und wir müssen
ständig nach korrigieren das muss man
leider schon sagen weil auch die großen
ziele die wir ja bestimmt haben sie
versagt ihm erziele
noch hat sich der co2 uhrzeiger eben
noch nicht abgeknickt und umgedreht die
korona pandemie hat natürlich etwas
gespart weil wir aufgehört haben zu
fliegen und die mobilität und auch der
konsum zurück gegangen ist aber das sind
leider nur sieben prozent von dem was
wir eigentlich schaffen müssen also ja
es ist vorher gesagt dass wir bis 20.30
bis 2040 je nachdem welches modell
genutzt wird die ersten ice rein
taktischen sommer haben werden das
bedeutet also mehr als unter 15 prozent
obwohl schwindet die antarktis bewegt
sich langsamer dort ist nur in regionen
schon der starke effekte des
klimawandels zu sehen auch dort mit aber
das meer enorm schnell viel wärmer und
auch die atmosphäre aber die antarktis
wird saarland nicht so schnell reagieren
wie die akte ist weil sonst ehrlich
gesagt du die man so im englischen sagt
es werden aber noch mehr polar flächen
ich war gerade in österreich und das
schicksal der alpinen netzer oder der
gletscher weltweit ist ein
fürchterliches wenn man dort ist und mit
den leuten spricht den bauern den
menschen die dort leben den
tourismusbetrieben
wenn man dort hingeht und sieht wie
schnell die gletscher weichen dann kann
man einfach immer nur sagen es ist doch
so klar wir haben so viele bilder davon
will ist es so einfach für uns menschen
die konsequenzen unseres handelns direkt
zu sehen es kann die nicht so schwer
sein jetzt in richtung gutes handeln zu
schwenken
dann machen sie damit auch noch mal
deutlich dass man wirklich die sachen in
zusammenhang sieht es ist nicht nur als
in der arktis schmilzt sondern eben auch
die gletscher und wenn man sich bilder
an guckt da können wir auch im
livestream zu machen gletscher vor 100
jahren und heute ist fürchterlich mit
einem wissenschaftler durch die schweiz
gefahren und er hat mir dann gezeigt wie
dort alles geschmolzen ist und kleiner
geworden ist und das ist erschreckend
und man kann in eine andere region ja
auch noch schauen in russland zum
beispiel gibt es ja gigantische flächen
die wo der permafrost sozusagen
dominierend ist und wenn der schmilzt da
macht sich cornelia kochten jetzt
gedanken was passiert denn wenn der
permafrost nicht nur in sibirien und
russland sondern überall komplett
wegschmilzt kann man diesen prozess denn
überhaupt noch stoppen also nicht nur
ein sondern auch die idee permafrost
aber ist wieder die saison los gebrochen
und forscher von uns zum beispiel wie du
großes unterwegs den permafrost zu
vermessen die forscher vom abi potsdam
eine strategie rund um die arktis mit
ihren internationalen kollegen so
ähnlich auch wie es bei mosaik gelungen
ist international mit mit 20 nationen
zusammen den zustand der arktis zu
vermessen
dann rund um das anrainer betrieb um den
nordpol
die temperaturanstiege im boden zu
messen wir haben ja jetzt schon wieder
unglückliche 24 grad in sibirien und die
beobachten dass tatsächlich die wärme
sich enorm schnell schneller als
vorhergesagt in den boden fortsetzt also
die böden erwärmen sich das führt zum
tauen des eises und ihr arbeiten an
dieser frage was passiert als nächstes
in den permafrost regionen liegen
massive mengen gefrorener pflanzenreste
und gerade in den küstenregionen die auf
und fallen jetzt mehr wo alles soll es
mit hungrigen mikroorganismen die die
aus hessen und noch mehr co2 in die luft
pusten
und das ist leider die schlecht
nachricht immer wieder müssen wir darauf
hinweisen dass wenn die erde sich
erwärmt dann haben wir lauter lauter
speichert zwischenspeicher für
kohlenstoff im boden im meer in den
verletzten gehen die luft gehen sie hier
waldbränden dass ihr das brennen was wir
sehen das ist ja eine reaktion auf dem
zimmer brannten und macht dann aber noch
mehr co2 in die atmosphäre was auch
wieder zu erwerben beitrag und dieser so
genannte runaways dieser schnelle
feedback effekt den versuchen wir alle
zu erfassen und zu beschreiben und so
ist ein ganz dringliche notwendigkeit
für die klimamodelle endlich die
permafrost reaktionen also das traum des
permafrosts das entlassen von der co2
und methan in die atmosphäre und ins
meer
das mit aufzunehmen und also nochmal
nach zu korrigieren das tut mir leid
dass auch ernsthaft so wie mein kollege
des stechens zu sagen zu müssen dass
diese nachrichten zusammengenommen alle
nicht gut sind und einfach nur sagen wir
brauchen nicht nur ehrgeizige ziele wird
auch ein ganz klarer handlungsoptionen
wie kommen wir da hin wo gehen müssen
frau professor lucius klarer kann man
das nicht sagen
sarah kann man das nicht erklären die
spirale dass es wirklich schlimm ist
nicht fünf vor zwölf sondern eigentlich
12 uhr
und das ist allerhöchste zeit wird wie
dirk steffens schon gesagt hat
optimistisch zu bleiben optimistisch zu
bleiben denn die energie des optimismus
braucht man um die ärmel hochzukrempeln
aber man sollte sie schnell hochkrempeln
und etwas tun ganz ganz herzlichen dank
für ihre erläuterung für ihre
erklärungen für die antworten auf die
vielen fragen großes dankeschön bleiben
wir optimismus auch optimistisch und
dann wollen wir hoffen dass die appelle
und die erklärung von ihnen beiden auch
überall angekommen sind ganz herzlichen
dank viele grüße nach bremerhaven
viele grüße an alle optimisten
ja dann danken wir den beiden experten
und danken ganz herzlich ihnen auch für
ihr interesse das waren glaube ich
interessante hochspannende erklärungen
auf das essentielle fragen wir haben
alle begriffen es geht nicht nur um die
netten eisbären und deren zukunft
sondern es geht um unsere zukunft und
warum das ganze so ist ganz herzlichen
dank für ihr interesse
tschüss den arm noch oder wieder sehen